quelques bonnes semaines il faut chanter
le black shark 2 est sorti a pas
longtemps le black shark de pro
evolution du blackjack 2 la question à
se poser c'est est-ce que ce black chat
de pro est vraiment plus intéressant que
le black shark 2,6 que comme au mois de
juillet session du mal à prononcer black
shark j'accroche un petit peu dessus
mais il ya un truc trouve tellement
intéressant en tout cas je peux vous
dire dès maintenant ça qu'on a tout
nouveau packaging qui est cool
il ya plus de choses dans cette boîte
qui n'y avait dans l'autre il ya
toujours les options en plus mon jeu
vous le montrer et surtout un smartphone
que vraiment intéressant pour le gaming
mais la question c'est est-ce qui est
vraie différence entre le black shark de
l'acte chaque de pro est ce qu'il faut
aller sur l'oc plutôt que 100 autres
c'est ce qu'on va regarder et vous allez
voir que franchement ça cette petite
bête elle est quand même plutôt sympa
[Musique]
bonjour
est-ce que c'est pas tout mignon ce truc
le black shark de proue il ya une
différence déjà regardé commencé comme
ça ils étaient beaucoup plus bombée
avant sur le blackjack deux consoles la
csac de pro il est beaucoup moins bombée
mais par contre il est toujours très
cool et il ya plein d'intérêt venez pas
là on va se poser dans le coin alors la
première chose avec ce black csac de
pros on met les éclairages en place ça
va tout va bien tout est bien tout est
bien chez vous est-ce que ça va oui le
marquer en commentaire si tout se passe
bien la maison c'est tout va bien ça
c'est important on garde clairement
laden du black shark deux parce que on
est dans le même produit c'est juste une
évolution évolution professionnelle il
ya quelques évolutions technologiques
j'accroche ya quelques évolutions
technologiques quelques évolutions au
niveau du design et surtout ce qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est une évolution
au niveau du packaging
parce que il ya plus de choses et que je
trouve qu'il ya eu un vrai boulot de
fait au niveau de l'esprit au niveau de
l'idée de l'ama regardez moi cette jolie
petite boîte comme elle est mignonne
tout joli tout sympathique alors en fait
tu regardes hop on va se décaler sent un
peu plus bas voilà comme ça
regardez alors la petite boîte déjà les
cool le packaging est beaucoup plus
intéressant est beaucoup plus jolie que
ce conte avec le black shark deux
versions où je dirais standard black
shark design ils ont fait un boulot
l'assise enfin beau boulot là dessus ça
s'est vraiment bien réussi surtout
varela le petit dégradé de verts trouve
ça chouette alors on va seul ouvrir va
pas passer des heures tard bien pâle et
puis ouvrir ce truc
voilà alors en fait lorsque vous
l'ouvrez dès le départ vous avez le
smartphone qui est positionné dans son
écrin avec le petit slogan bantous
compet et la tac vous voulez alors il y
là dedans vous retrouver le même slogan
ici qui est normalement autour du
smartphone vous en douterez donc ça
c'est plutôt que le fouet déjà il ya une
vraie notion d'expérience yale on arrive
le slogan ça me donne la ds le manque
vraiment ce qu'on va faire
bon on est sur un smartphone de gaming
on s'en doutera on retombe à lever cette
partie là et ça je trouve ça cool parce
que regarder
regardez ça comme si malins les petites
accroches qu'ils ont fait des ailerons
de requins pour me dire la trappe et wii
black shark 1 le requin noir enfoncera
douter et bien on l'a on allait la ronde
noir du requin tout ça coule donc ça
nous marquent bien ce qu'on a ici on a
le gamepad qu'un pad stand câble pour
adaptateur casque
et je trouve ça pas mal et regardez là
en fait l'idée c'est que lorsque je vous
ai montré le black shark deux versions
premier est sombre d'axalto il pas le
blackjack deux pros eh bien il fallait
acheter tous les accessoires en plus
c'est à dire la coque qui est toujours
le cas
le petit gamepad version droite ce qui
est toujours le cas mais par contre là
dedans vous avez le dncaj de gauche qui
est inclus et ça c'est bien parce que ça
commence à vous apporter un petit peu
l'expérience de façon plus native et ça
c'est intéressant regardez vous avez
votre petit gamepad qu'il est là il va
venir se clipper et une petite coque qui
a été rien je vous montrais parce que
sans ça ne va pas pouvoir de m ce que si
vous voulez le mettre bas ça ne tient
pas c'est un petit peu ballot si vous ne
vous inquiétez pas complètement normal
ici vous avez un câble usb usb cédric
est juste là il est trop mignon
vous avez un adaptateur suis pas très
fan c'est de l'usb sévère de la prise
jack ça c'est parce que vous n'avez pas
de prise jack sur ce smartphone ça c'est
pas nouveau c'était pareil sans l'autre
le problème c'est que lorsque vous allez
venir poser au petit contrôleur d'un
côté l'autre mais ça ça devient
complètement inutilisable on trouvera la
solution est moins intéressant ce que
nous propose asus avec son rock funk de
donc ça c'est bon voilà c'est bien mais
pas complètement bien c'est pas
extrêmement complètement abouti à bord
sur un black shark 3 7 6 4
hop ils vont l'être dans sa salle à la
vous avez ensuite ici pour toute la
partie adaptateur je vous le montre vite
chez mais il n'y a rien de bien dingo
l'intérieur il est bien planqué il est
beau et mignon et performant et les
puissants on en fait plein plein de
choses regardez-moi ça comme c'est
mignon et ensuite on continue avec cette
partie là qui est elle aussi très très
judicieuse puisqu'elle vous permet de
base de mettre votre smartphone jardin
de protéger légèrement vous venez de
mettre dedans c'est pas la protection la
plus dingue c'est pas la protection la
plus jolie on va pas se mentir mais par
contre ça vous permet de venir
positionner votre petite manette comme
ça ici vous allez à lui met directement
en dessous comme lorsque vous et montrez
dans la première version hop elle se
connectera directement en bluetooth
dessus mais au moins ça vous permet
d'avoir une première expérience de jeu
de votre smartphone alors bon c'est bien
mais c'est pas complètement abouti parce
qu'il nous manque quand même cette
petite partie sur la droite et là il
faut venir dépenser plus d'argent je
vous parle de prix juste à la fin de la
vidéo comme ça vous saurez tout et vous
allez pouvoir avoir la meilleure
expérience sur ce black cats de pro donc
ce qu'il vous faut sur les petits
accessoires alors j'ai gardé juste cette
partie là j'ai enlevé la sq elle est sur
le côté je les relis intérieur parce
qu'on va devenir
utiliser cette petite coque alors qui
est une coque mais qui ne sert pas
complètement de coop qui sert surtout
c'est des petites glissières sur le côté
si vous le voyez bien comme s'ils ont
des petits glissière qui vous servent à
insérer votre pad alors vous prenez ça
vous preniez votre smartphone vous
prenez vous le mettez comme une petite
coque de protection jusque là tout va
bien c'est simple ces pratiques sur la
partie gauche vous allez venir glisser
çà vous prenez attendez je me vient d'en
face vous le prenez vous le mettez vous
le glisse et qui sans ça c'est cool
voulons donc l'autre partie qu'il faut
acheter en plus une fois de plus
donnerait des tarifs à la fin il est là
vous tiré de tak vient là mon petit
lapin et là vous allez vraiment venir
augmenter significativement l'expérience
de jeu vous le prenez une fois de plus
vous le mettez dedans et là vous
retrouvez avec la même tronche que vous
aviez avec le blackjack de dos d'un
point de vue esthétique le black shark
de broc est une évolution du black shark
de on garde le même nom ça me paraît
normal par contre nativement vous avez
saccagé dans la boîte que vous n'aviez
pas avec le black shark deux ans m qu'en
est il réellement en terme d'expérience
on va regarder ça ensemble avant de
parler d'expérience vous parlez du
produit en lui même ont un smartphone
tout je trouve pas mal y aller vraiment
les codes du gaming il est un petit peu
lourd 205 g bon ce n'est pas extrêmement
grave on a un capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui déverrouille des fois bien
et des fautes un peu difficile c'est un
capteur optique à ça dépend un bon
relais fonctionne bien donc plutôt bon
exemple à l'époque comment effectivement
vous avez dit repositionner votre doigt
dessus je vous le dis pas plus on a
quasiment le même design le dot un peu
moins bombée vous avez ce petit bouton
qui fait toute la force de ce smartphone
qui vous permet de rentrer dans le mode
chaque tag ont poussé et paf vous
arrivez dans le moteur donc comme ça
c'est un mode spécial gaming on va se
marier dans quelques instants avec
quelques jeux qui sont à l'intérieur
vous venu ensuite le désactiver hop vous
sortez du morte sharks du mode chaque
vous avez vous dormir la nuit mais pour
l'éteindre ici là vous avez des petites
petites led qui sont planqués ici et ici
qui vont venir salut mais lorsque vous
allez jouer je vous montre tout à
l'heure également le bouton de volume en
dessous vous retrouvez de l'usbc pour
venir leur charge et vous avez ici votre
tiroir de cartes sinti micro qui situé
sur le bas également vous avez un micro
pour la réduction de brut est ici et
vous avez deux haut parleurs en façade
bien la toile up de haut parleurs en
façade un ici et ici pour apporter
vraiment en termes de d'immersion à ce
que vous avez bien joué et qui
fonctionne vraiment vraiment bien que ça
c'est plutôt bien mais surtout un des
points forts de ce smartphone ces sondes
écrans fabriqués par samsung sans écran
de six bières
trente neuf pouces ratio 19 points 5/9
2340 par 1080 pixels à 403 pixels par
pouces un écran qui a été travaillé pour
éviter la fatigue oculaire qu'on nous
vend une pression tactile de 0,3 mm pour
le gaming sensible à la pression qui
arrivent pas réellement le quantifier ce
qui est sûr c'est que lorsque je joue
directement sur l'écran je trouve qu'il
fonctionne bien il est réactif
après vous dire 0,3 mm personnellement
comme ça je vais pas vous lire je vous
parle a une fois de plus de l'audio et
bien vous dresse donc ses deux haut
parleurs en façade
le seul truc c'est que lorsque les
contrôleurs sont branchés je voulais
monter tout à l'heure une seule puce
vous n'êtes pas pouvoir venir brancher
sur votre adaptateur dont vous n'êtes
pas pour harnes et utiliser un casque
filaire il faut donc se retourner dans
le casque bluetooth parce que vous avez
du bluetooth 5.0 a pété x a pété x hd
peut aussi faire tourner duel des as et
jusque là on garde sensiblement les
mêmes codes que ce qu'on avait avec le
black shark de là il va y avoir une
évolution au niveau de la performance
vous avez un stand dragonne 855 plus et
non pas 1 855 comme vous avez sur le
black shark 2 celui-ci cadencé à 2 96
gygax contre 2,84 giguère qui a pas non
plus un écart énorme
vous avez toujours la possibilité
d'avoir soit 8 soit 12 giga de ram
lp ddr4 x ça c'est la même chose que
vous aviez dans le black shark 2 par
contre cette fois-ci vous avez du
stockage 128 ou 256 gia ce n'est pas de
lui fs 2.1 celle du ffs 3.0 qui
permettra d'aller plus vite en lecture
et en écriture
ça permet d'aller un peu plus vite mais
c'est pas non plus complètement
révolutionnaire d'un côté on le voit on
n'est pas sur un axe sharks 3 on est sur
un du lac chaque deux pros donc un
modèle qu'ils aient évolué par rapport
aux modèles d'avant il n'ya pas de
révolution mais une évolution et côté
performances envoie du bois avec un
score se rend tout de 481 1323 ce qui le
classe à la quatrième position entre le
one + 7 et pro et leurs ennemis x2 pro
donc un smartphone qui dépote qui va
bien car en termes de gaming est
vraiment intéressant on va y venir
par contre l'autonomie vous avez une
batterie de 4000 millan paire eur et 6
et la même batterie que vous avez dans
le black shark de il ya rien de bien
d'un guide est compatible coach arcade
plus de qualcomm
vous tenez un jour et demi avec deux
jours si vraiment vous ils couler si
vous jouez forcément si vous jouez
beaucoup et bien moment le niveau de
batterie va fond comme neige au soleil
kdc millions salariat vous avez
effectivement déjà des petits refrains
qui peut bleuté puis surtout vous avez
c'est l'aide ici qui veut vraiment vous
le type est il un vrai adn de guînes
ce smartphone au niveau de l'os on
tourne sur un android 9 bail avec la
surcouche c'est john ou ailleurs je vous
dis notamment ce chat space op tac qui
est là qui nous remettre vraiment dans
l'expérience de gaming avec vous je
voulais pouvoir venir choisir ici des
pouvoirs me réglez vos contrôleurs je
n'ai pas encore branchez vous allez
avoir accès à votre liste de jeux qui
est situé juste ici vous avez vos
applications et lorsque vous voulez
jouer un jeu perdre et hop vous scrollé
ici et là vous avez tous vos raccourcis
le beau jeu game pad master touch votre
wifi
les notifications oui ou non vous voyez
du coup c'est vraiment pas mal vous
pouvez lire tout paramétrer ça vous
permet d'aller plus loin l'expérience de
gagner surtout ce smartphone il est
vraiment cool lorsqu'on va venir mettre
les accessoires parce que même si sans
les accessoires ils fonctionnent et vous
pouvez complètement l'utiliser avec les
accessoires ont conclu qu'une dimension
alors après faut savoir qu'il faut dire
quand même les maps et on me dira ma tvo
touche parce que dans vos jeux ils ne
sont pas paramétré il faut venir
effectivement les branches et les maps
et et là au moins on donne aux
dimensions leur expérience de jeu
première chose à faire il faut venir les
allumer leur celui ci était lui mais il
faut venir à lui mais le deuxième
l'attaquent
au sam allume mon contrôleur et se
connecte directement voyeur bon je peux
venir naviguer comme ça dessus ça vous
fait une petite souris si vous le voyez
là loyer ou alors pop ça me fait me lier
comme ça ce que vous constituez s'est
passé dans le paf
le mode sharks hélas en directement dans
l'immersion allez c'est parti on va se
faire un petit modern combat 5
alors je vous dis tout de suite je suis
pas un expert au jeu je suis même pas
très très bon donc m'en voulez pas ces
gisements très rapidement devenir très
facilement déplacé l'âge avance on
recule l'âge veille sur le côté et là
normalement j'ai mon arme qui est matée
alors vérifier quand même ce que je fais
c'est que je vais dans mon gamepad donc
là je les ai m'apaiser paramétrer ici up
tak tak j'ai tout paramétrer et ça ce
que l'expérience est quand même
vachement bien alors je suis pas un
dingo non plus à dessus je vous dis une
fois de plus j'ai des grenades que je
peux venir lancer ici hop je lance ma
part toucher n'importe quoi là tout se
passe bien mais par contre venu talent
d'expérience de jeu c'est quand même
vachement bien je suis nul je voulais
dit je suis mort mais par contre son
expérience de jeu il faut que c'est
vraiment pratique vous avez des boutons
sans dessus la cij et deux boutons là
deux boutons là j'ai mes quatre boutons
j'ai réussi mon petit joystick et j'ai
tout mon pavé tactile ici j'aime et
quatre boutons aux attentes sur un jeu
que je maîtrise mieux
vias phaneuf peut mettre le turbo je
peux venir ensuite ici bien rap et je
choisis je veux aller là ils vont tous
me prendre je peut tartiner je roule tac
je dérape
je vous parlais de 5 à 2 go regardez
vous aviez petite led lorsque vous
appuyez sur les boutons ça vous activez
votre l'aide en bas ça vous activote
l'aide en haut je trouve ça plutôt
rigolo d'ailleurs lorsque vous allez
jouer ça apporte un peu plus ce côté
immersif je vous conseille une petite
manip au niveau de votre écran vous
allez dans l'affichage des ied en
couleurs vous êtes par des formats de
naturel je conseille le mode cinéma qui
va raviver les couleurs qui donnera un
peu plus de punch et de tonus mais
pourquoi pas le mode protection des yeux
vous venir un petit peu réglé ici là
vous avez été trop chaud parce que c'est
pas terrible
vous ne mettez pas contre moi sont
froids bull remonte un peu pour casser
un peu ce côté un peu trop bloqué pour
venir reposer davantage vos yeux je
trouve que c'est pas mal vous avez aussi
la protection clignotantes un maul est
de faible luminosité peut venir
l'activé directement ici a pris pas mal
de petits réglages pour venir voir mes
faux comme ça déjà ça casse un petit peu
ce côté un peu trop bleuté ça vient un
petit peu plus reposer vos yeux ça me
semble plutôt pas mal
qualité de l'écran est bien connu en
europe zoom un peu plus son stéréo haut
parleurs ici haut parleurs ici donc pour
visionner aussi du contenu multimédia
série ce que vous voulez tous nous fait
plaisir même si voix sur youtube vient
pouvez le faire ça marche c'est confort
c'est chouette ça ne vous aura pas
échappé on a aussi des petits modules
photos ici donc ça veut dire qu'on peut
faire des photos avec en gros vous avez
deux capteurs 40 8 mégapixels c'est la
sony mx 5 186 la techno 4 pixels en un
qui vous servira pour faire des photos
en faible luminosité
elle ouvre à f 1.75 ok ça marche si vous
avez un deuxième c'est un téléobjectif
12 mégapixels f 2.2 zoom optique x 2 ça
fait le taf il ya pas de fioritures
c'est simple efficace il ya les vans
d'une petite caméra qui est planqué ici
qui vous servira pour laisser le fiva
mégapixels 4xl en 1 également f 2.0
bon y'a rien de bien complètement dingue
là dessus ça marche dit vous avez votre
jeune optique x 2 on peut venir ensuite
vient aux places dont un peu plus avec
june numérique
vous avez jusqu'au 10 mai c'est pas
terrible je vous conseille le x 1 x 2
pour un truc est correcte a comparé des
vidéos vidéos courtes portrait bon ça
c'est un grand standard photo en 48
mégapixels ça n'apporte pas grand-chose
mode de nuit pourquoi pas bon on n'est
pas sur un photophone on est à tu vas
être calme et toi ça fait du bruit les
côtés on est patient ça suffit on n'est
pas sur un photophone on laissera
smartphones qui fait des photos qui fait
des photos de plutôt bonne qualité là
vous avez une photo qui étaient prises
avec le capteur principal ça fonctionne
les couleurs sont assez justes je trouve
ont ensuite dire avec le zoom x 2 ça
fait le taf c'est correct ses propres
des vous avez surtout
ce n'est pas terrible caméra principale
12 fois de sa fait le taf on a des
couleurs qui sont quand même plutôt pas
trop mal rendue caméra principale x 2
kad merad selphy caméra de celle fille
elle fait le taf
si ce n'est que j'ai une espèce de coupe
d'iroquois ce matin un petit peu bizarre
voyez comme ça mais elle fait le taf
une fois de plus on est sur un
smartphone de guémy qui fait des photos
et les photos qui sont plutôt bonnes
mais on n'est pas sur un photophone donc
on s'attend pas à voir la lune voilà
donc ce joli petit smartphone regardez
là comme il est mignon il est beau il
est chaud mais sympa est-ce qu'il peut
vous tentez sur le lac tchad 2 et
surtout avant toute chose on a parlé du
prix oui mais si on parle pas du prix ça
peut le faire alors qu'on est tous tel
un paon du prix
ce black shark boy 8 +128 il coûte pas
moins de 599 euros
il faut savoir que vous avez en plus ce
petit accessoire là que vous n'aviez pas
avec le black chat 2 pour qu'au début du
black star de projets une avancée à 50
euros de plus mais vous avez un
accessoire en plus il coûte quelque
chose comme 30 40 euros
donc ça vaut le coup aucune évolution
matérielle un peu plus de choses à
l'intérieur et surtout une boîte quand
même beaucoup plus mignonne et si vous
voulez la version 12 plus 956 giga de
stockage gars vous êtes à 699 euros au
lieu de 649 euros
dans l'absolu ça fonctionnait à frayer
aussi deux accessoires robin venir ou
qu'on va venir acheter en plus c'est
celui là
voyez ça ça s'achète en plus et ça ça
coûte 37 euros 90 ouailles
ce serait tout le temps b monsieur
catastrophe aujourd'hui et puis vous
avez la petite coque aussi une coque de
protection mais qui nous servent aussi
accroché vos manettes qui coûte 19,90
donc ce qui fait que si vous voulez la
version 8 +128 pour aller 660 euros
eh bien vous avez la complète vous avez
un smartphone de gaming qui fonctionne à
100 tonnes de gaming qui est efficace
qui est une évolution n'y a pas une
grosse évolution c'est pas une
révolution par rapport aux black shark 2
black shark de pros comme son nom
l'indiqué va aller un peu plus loin
termes de performances pour être de
faire un peu plus de choses mais il n'y
a pas la grosse révolution la grosse
révolution je pense qu'on l'aura avec le
bel acte sharks 3 je l'espère en 2020
cependant je trouve pas mal celui là ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
vous vous trouvez par rapport aux black
cats de black stars 2 vs black tide
roh dur à dire jack black shark de
province asus rog phone deux que je
trouve aussi intéressant et je trouve
que bien que vous ayez des contrôleurs
il se permet donc d'avoir une expérience
augmenté avec je dirais le asus rog fun
ii et bien vous avez beaucoup de
produits dans l'écosystème coûteux
relativement cher attention est aussi
une notion prix là dedans à prendre en
compte mais si vous étiez plusieurs
accessoires vous allez pouvoir avoir
différents types d'expériences de gaming
alors ta vie que celui-ci vous avez un
seul dont pas un seul vous l'avez sur le
smartphone et vous l'avez avec les
petits contrôleur that's it c'est tout
il n'y a pas d'autre chose mais ça
fonctionne c'est plutôt bien
vous dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire et si vous avez des
questions ou interrogations suggestion
vous pouvez y aller vous mettez tout en
bas et n'oubliez pas vous pouvez prendre
aussi vous le contrôle sur la chaîne
décider quels seront les produits qui
vont et et c'est d'ailleurs ce produit
dont il a été choisi par les membres
vous avez choisi je les fais je vais
exécuter à vos ordres vous pouvez donc
cliquer sur le bouton rejoindre qui est
quelque part ici en dessous pour venir
choisir les produits qui vont être testé
très prochainement sur ce je vous
embrasse plus de gros becs et je vous
dis à très bientôt à demain même
d'ailleurs pourquoi tu n'y as pas le
trader si ce projet vous intéresse je
vous ai mis un lien en bas de la
descente pour les states coup d'oeil si
il vous fait de l'oeil ou à lille ou à
demain